ciao sono fermati sull inter torres
oggi nuova challenge a grandissima
richiesta siccome mi chiedete sempre di
rifare la sales indovina il colore dello
slam
questo no ma sale in cui dobbiamo
indovinare il tipo di slime e poi anche
il colore dello slam
quindi iniziamo subito in più oppure se
sapete che io mi dimentico sempre quanti
punti ha fatto agli monete fare un punto
non premerò così metterà ha ricordato in
contributi
ho fatto che ovviamente anche voi
segnatevi punti a casa
segnatevi conti alla fine del video
vediamo subito io so se avete vinto voi
come sempre mettetevi comodi palatine
pop corn e iniziamo subito ovviamente
come sempre giocate anche volto nei
commenti ok line numero uno secondo voi
questo un fishbowl vuole un pò slime
numero uno prima di londra allora
secondo me è un forum perchè non lo
stato ad un contenitore mi sembrava un
po non è un po la numero
uno sbocco non vediamo poche bene tra
l'altro anche un pò di forio e quindi un
punto per me e anche voi che avete
subito fu un club
avete un punto tenetelo a mente ok
tengono due secondo voi è 13 metallico
un flop slime vediamo se si vede
qualcosina in anteprima primo che lo 8
donne su 10 secondi che abbiamo numero
due il clero nei commenti in back
all'hip hop lo secondo me e blog
non lo so se mi inganna i pallini
colorati che ha disegnato sopra però io
dico però vediamo nick è una sorta di
con un po bronzato offline bellissimo il
colore
i punti tante quindi se avete scritto
metalli slime avete fatto in tutto io
son fermato a un punto
ok ai 13 secondo goletti quindi non mi
ricordo se italiano fiction box live
bello corposo che è molto denso oppure e
cicli denso o scicli
secondo me 3 è detto scrivete voi che
come team una freddezza oggi clip
vediamo quindi bello dentro e se non
avete indovinato avete fatto alcun altro
tutto ok 13 quando abbiamo indovinare
quale di questi quattro e quello viola
quindi numero aspetta ma chi siamo
la numero 4
4 quale di questi quattro slime è viola
secondo voi il numero uno il numero 2 e
numero 3 ori numero 4 nella storia a
casa e dico che quello viola è il numero
due questo qua a destra scrivete voi nei
commenti il numero 4 dove il viola
secondo cui effettuiamo un fold offerti
[Musica]
prima di questo abbiamo quindi non era
né l'ultimo a destra
[Musica]
vediamo freddo quinto anche questo è
bianco quindi no deciditi di amore è il
primo in alto a sinistra temete scritto
giusto avete fatto un punto e col 40
viola e dovrebbe feste
ok la numero 5 quale di questi è comoda
il numero 1 numero 2 e numero 3 con un
numero porto quasi numeri così più
facile ricordarcelo
allora secondo me come prima aveva messo
in culo primo forfait da solo ha perso
nell'ultimo io dico che il numero
quattro è pronta
scrivetelo nei commenti fly numero 5
quale è quello rosa e vediamo subito
[Musica]
allora il numero uno non è rotta dai 44
ma perché fa finta numero 2 non numero 3
fatto fate nemmeno quindi ecco le loro
tante avete scritto 23 avete preso un
punto io sono sempre cantoni o che è il
numero se poi dobbiamo indovinare il 6
giugno dobbiamo illumina rete il colore
della destra arancione conto molto
non so perché forse perché si è rivolto
ai soli queste decorazioni ma secondo me
arancione scrivete voi che come figura
se ha ragione o rota vediamo se
soprattutto tutto
[Applauso]
[Musica]
avete fatto un altro punto è viva line
al numero 7 secondo poi e blu o il
giallo
allora io mi baso sempre sulle
decorazioni sopra e mi sembra che ci sia
più gialloblù numero 7 io di controllo
si mettono nei commenti il numero 7 che
con esse qui vediamo
[Musica]
tutto per me mi ricordo quanti posizione
485 facciamo quattro ma il numero 8
quando indovina il colore senza nessun
indizio è ancora più difficile così ma
io prendo uno dei colori che palle qui
sopra e dico viola secondo me numero 8
più alti del timone commenti come
racconto vediamo
[Musica]
era rotta per questo mi misero mick ma
non vado a questo punto dovete line
numero 9 mi sembra secondo voi questo
slime e nero o e arcobaleno un
interessante questa allora io spero che
sia la quale che sono stato messo nel
marcobaleno quindi non lo so io mi butto
e dico arcobaleno voi il numero 9
scrivete mela o arcobaleno vediamo
[Musica]
dio
tante palline
consente ma secondo quelli protetti che
quello non c'erano tante palline con la
notte ma allo slam rimaneva bianco
quindi cosa facciamo arcobaleno nero
facciamo che siccome le palline l'anno
colorate che insomma il cupa lenta e non
è solo portare un punto
ok ma il numero 10 indovinate i colori
quinto permettersi più di un colore
numero 10 io dico non lo so viola e
giallo noi vetro con i commenti pe diamo
[Musica]
ma se rosa arancio giallo verde blu e
viola è impossibile indovinare tutti
questi colori se voi avete scritto che
questi colori oppure anche male no
oppure anche colori avesse preso un
punto numero 11 quale di questi è ver
del 1 e 2 3 o il 4
io mi butto dico che il numero uno e
verde scrivetelo bene come il numero 11
quale aprono berte prendiamo
[Musica]
quindi non era membro tubo e vediamo se
con il botto in genere sempre l'ultimo
forse un vero contenuto punto sono sei
punti per otto che si bisogna indovinare
quale ai blitz per allora io non ho
finora non ho mai a contatto sul 3
quindi numero 12 b col numero 3 scrivete
voi nei commenti
vediamo subito
[Musica]
paterson e belletti che questo non hai
più
[Musica]
noi ulteri mail l'inter quindi non
prendere su tutto numero uno di questi
glitter e all 11 serate detto numero
troppo basso tutto nero sopra dai numeri
presi secondo voi che colore è io non
esprimo di una crisi un colore chiaro
questo sotto questione rosso tecnico
nero lo stesso avete voi nei commenti il
numero 13
vediamo uno spigolo scapito bianco rosa
chiaro ok se avete il sito bianco o rosa
tutti
avete preso un punto io rimango sensi
non mero fattore si seguono questo
sospender blu diverse e non lo sto mi
butto e dico blu
scrivete voi i commenti 14 blu o verde
vediamo
[Musica]
zero per indovinato prendete un altro
punto nulla 15 qual è secondo voi il
colore di maglia sono sicura che è uno
di questi cinque cover che sono sopra e
non lo so un punto dico posto numero 15
rosso vediamo anche questo numero non mi
ricordo se mi si se non sbaglio c'è
scritto il tuo colore preferito sopra
quindi proviamo a vivendo sul colore
preferito magari salerno secolo recapito
quindi numero 16 stile piuttosto come
avrei preferito nei commenti vediamo se
è lo stesso di questo slime allora ha
detto mi piacciono celeste mi piace in
rosa mi piace il nostro ma in questo
caso vado con il celeste vediamo
[Musica]
che bello allora se avete detto uno di
questi prodotti c'è casey contenimento
se avete fatto il punto perché
tecnicamente centrato quindi mette tutti
allora al numero numero 17 secondo voi e
che ora o è stata sandra oh scoppiando
quello cornice wow
allora io dico rosa che mettono poi nei
commenti crediamo ragazzi e viola state
è scritto che ora a ma che presto un
altro punto numero di sato indovina il
colore secondo me è uno di questi colori
sopra e dico giallo vediamo
[Musica]
dopo era verde numero diciotto ragazzi
questo è l'ultimo e sinceramente un
percorso abbiamo già fatto perché questi
sembrano tutti uguali ma cambia il
colore va bene l'ultimo concentriamoci
il numero 18 quale di questi death toll
io mi butto e dico il numero due
vediamo
[Musica]
mi sa che ma avere il numero due il
numero uno no
[Musica]
no quindi figurano tutte numero 4
è il numero 43 testino numero 4 fate un
altro punto
ok regime inter channel semi diritto
lasciate un bel laica 10.000 max andrò
farne un'altra quindi mi ha chiamato
spalleggiate condividete la con incontri
amici vediamo quanti punti fanno
scrivetemi nei commenti il 4 punti avete
fatto io l'ho fine ho fatto sette punti
vediamo stesso in the riusciti a
batterli e ora vi lascio fa quattro o
due cappellini in cui potete fare altre
merciale già subite divertenti cliccate
su quella che preferite e buona migliore